[Music]
hello and welcome to the reason
Roundtable I'm Peter suderman filling in
for Matt Welch who is so many time zones
away that he might as well be on another
planet joining me today are my regular
co-panelists Nick Gillespie and
Catherine Menge Ward as well as special
guest Eric Bame everyone say hello howdy
hello happy Monday Peter on this week's
episode we'll talk about the unusual
unexpected outcome of last week's
midterm election what went right what
went wrong and what we still don't know
plus what Elon musk's Twitter takeover
tells us about the state of the internet
and Free Speech online in 2022 alright
gang it has been almost a full week
since the midterm election and we still
don't know the final results but this
much is clear Republicans radically
underperformed the red wave that was
predicted turned out to be a sad low
tide and that is why I'm going to call
this segment better dead than red the
GOP leader in the house Kevin McCarthy
had predicted a huge pickup of 60 seats
he had like a whole party ready uh where
he was going to celebrate this and he
just didn't even ever get up to the
podium at all or like came up at 2AM and
was like oh we'll have a majority by
tomorrow that didn't happen a 60 seat
pickup would have given Republicans a
commanding majority but as of this
morning Republicans still have not
definitively taken control of the house
while they are favored to do so it's
likely that they will end up with a slim
majority perhaps just a few seats
Democrats meanwhile will hold control of
the Senate and possibly even pick up a
seat Joe Biden has been doing what
amounts to a victory tour with Democrats
and their partisans feeling Vindicated
Democrats feel like they won the
argument that democracy was on the
ballot that abortion was on the ballot
that Medicare and Social Security were
at risk that Mega forces had taken over
the Republican party and that the GOP
was too crazy too extreme and too trumpy
to be trusted in short Joe Biden's come
on man kind of won and that happened
despite the fact that voters typically
turn against the party of a first-term
president during a midterm it happened
despite surveys that continued to show
that voters didn't much like Biden and
his fellow Democrats either
inflation and the economy were the top
priorities for voters and Republicans
had the edge on those issues as Amy
Walter the editor of the cook political
report tweeted we saw poll after poll
showing Democrats winning among voters
who rate Biden somewhat unfavorably
that's not happened before in five
midterms for which Pew research had data
somewhat disapprovers have never been
this supportive of the president's party
along the same lines the AP vote cast
survey found that people who identify as
Independents favored Democrats by Four
Points so Nick you wrote a book about
independence I've heard and my first
question goes to you it's simply a vague
recollection simply what happened here
why did voters stick with Democrats
despite raiding Biden's performance on
key issues so poorly
yeah and it's uh you know I certainly
was expecting a massive increase of at
least 35 seats in the house just based
on past examples of this type of stuff I
mean really
um you know and the best explanation I
think is that people are tired of
swinging from one extreme to another
which has been the the main stay of the
of the 21st century where and uh a party
gets two or four years in office and
gets voted out because they actually
perform they they follow through on what
they say they want to do and people are
enough already we want the other party I
think what happened here is that the
Republicans put forward an alternative
that was not even what they were doing
uh you know four years ago it was uh it
was extreme in the sense of a lack of
seriousness uh no political no actual
agenda other than being anti-biden and
the most prominent candidates for you
know Republicans were running
particularly in Senate races and things
like that were absolutely inexperienced
I mean they did not take politics
seriously but you know when you look at
even somebody like JD Vance in Ohio who
won his senate seat had no experience uh
J uh Blake Masters absolutely no
experience Herschel Walker no experience
mehmed Oz no experience and that
trickled through
um you know and people don't want to
replace bad policy with bad policy with
no experience
um and I think when you layer on top of
that questions about abortion you see
the you know the voters being like no
you know what uh we want abortion to be
uh legal we might want it to be rare but
we don't want that uh and then I think
the other thing that's interesting to me
is that the secretaries of State you
know this is the question of was
democracy on the ballot I think that's
overplayed but it's fascinating that the
only secretary of state Canada date who
was a true election denier who said that
Trump won the election uh you know in
2016 and won uh in 2020 and one office
was uh Chuck gray of Wyoming out of out
of a handful of people
um I think people are saying we don't
want the extreme of the Republican party
and that's what was on the ballot this
time I don't think this is an Embrace of
of Joe Biden or the Democratic agenda
which remains deeply unpopular but what
we're seeing instead of like an unstable
majority in a pendulum swinging you know
in a wide Arc people are starting to say
no you know what we want something
that's a little bit more serious and a
little less nuts
um and that's not moderation necessarily
but it is reality Eric to Nick's Point
how much of this is the results of
Democrats winning the argument versus
maybe Republicans losing it or not even
bothering to make an argument at all so
Democrats are crowing about how voters
bought you know uh they're lying about
you know democracy and abortion and
Medicare and Social Security all that
stuff's on the ballot right but you
wrote a piece about how in the run-up to
the 2020 presidential election
Republicans didn't even bother to offer
a new platform and this year Mitch
McConnell actually got mad at one of his
fellow Republican Senators Senator Rick
Scott for putting out really a fairly
vague proposed Republican agenda so how
much of this was just that Republicans
weren't putting forth uh an argument you
know like a a positive Vision that
voters could embrace
yeah I think that's a huge part of it uh
political scientists talk about
elections as being either choices or
referendums right like we have
referendum elections we have Choice
elections uh midterms frequently almost
always are referendums right especially
first term midterms uh is typically a
referendum on the the president's party
and the party that's in power and I
think it is based on that sort of
historical Trend that we had this
expectation of a red wave because uh
President Joe Biden is unpopular the
Democrats have been in charge for two
years and are uh generally pretty
unpopular with voters uh but this
election it turns out I don't think was
a referendum I think this election was a
choice election and that's why we see
sort of like scatter shot results here
that don't lend themselves easily to any
narrative we didn't get the Red Wave but
you did have uh Republicans win in many
places uh you also had results that
really cut against that and I think
that's because uh yeah it was ultimately
a choice election and Republicans did a
poor job of making the argument for
their half of that choice right for
their for their uh option on the ballot
I think because they wrongly assumed
that this was going to be an election in
which people were just going to go in
and vote against Democrats against Joe
Biden uh there was a moment and I led
the piece that I wrote about this uh
with this moment but that was on Fox
News the other day Jesse Waters who is
you know not necessarily the uh the most
brilliant political mind not exactly a
deep thinker but he had this moment I
happen to be flipping through the cable
news channels uh on Wednesday uh the day
after the election and there was this
moment where he just I think pulled a
sort of profound thought out of the the
milieu of of cable news and he he said
that there's just not a you know there's
not the hatred for Joe Biden out there
that there is for the clintons there's
not a hate Biden vote out there and I
think that is pretty much exactly right
uh Republicans have banked on the
anti-barack Obama the anti-hillary
Clinton vote for their successes
recently and they've uh not put forth
their own governing agenda they've not
put forth even the the most basic thing
like you were talking about that Rick
Scott proposed uh you know and and
they've relied purely on that backlash I
hate the guy in charge vote uh and that
wasn't there this time it was a choice
election and Republicans failed
Catherine the corollary to this is that
Republicans did have a good election in
one key state Florida where Ron DeSantis
and the Florida GOP absolutely clocked
their Democratic Rivals so DeSantis is
obviously a culture Warrior gotten a lot
of attention for kind of culture work
grandstanding but he's also a governor
with a record as an executive and
Florida voters seem pretty happy overall
with that record what does that tell us
about this election specifically but
also about the future of the Republican
party and sort of where all of this is
going where what's going to happen in
2024. you know I think I find myself in
a position that surprisingly I have in
common with many Americans that's not
always the case when it comes to
electoral outcomes
um which is that I
think that desantis's Victory while
while I don't like his governance
particularly and I really don't like his
rhetoric I think that his victory is
probably an okay sign for America
um and I don't quite know what to do
with that so the what I mean to say is
that
um because a lot of the Maga candidates
got
um chillact because of everything that
Eric just said and Nick just said about
um what I think these results say about
our relationship as a country to Joe
Biden's presidency and the Democratic
party generally
um you know I think DeSantis is coming
across as neither of those things he is
neither the thing that Joe Biden and the
Democratic party is nor is he Trump and
so him winning and being so popular I am
choosing to read at least is just on the
very very basic level Americans do not
want those other two things and if this
is what's on offer they'll take it so I
I do not read it particularly as a
referendum on his uh conduct as Governor
although I'm sure for many people it was
I see it more as a not this not that
let's try something else and I always
think that is a healthy uh impulse in
the American public because the two
major options are bad and uh this is
this is voters recognizing that and I
appreciate it Frank Luntz the kind of
political messaging Guru hosted a panel
of 15 Florida voters uh for the New York
Times recently and the headline that
came out of it was these 15 Florida
voters think Ron DeSantis is going
places like it or not and so even the
Democrats even the progressives who he
talked to really felt like DeSantis was
pushing forward and was sort of making a
name for himself and was uh you know was
achieving a kind of visibility
um nationally that was going to that was
going to make him the future in some
ways uh representative Peter Meyer of
Michigan who was one of these
Republicans who Democrats funded a kind
of more trumpy Maga a primary Challenger
and Peter Meyer lost as a result Peter
Meyer of course was just
and then of course the the trumpy
Challenger also lost the election
um Meyer was of course the uh successor
to Justin Amash and Justin amasha's
District Peter Meyer told the New York
Times quote we need DeSantis that should
be lit up in neon and projected onto the
side of the RNC so Nick is Ron DeSantis
the future of the Republican party and
do you think the ascent of DeSantis is
good or bad for Libertarians yeah so
those are very distinct questions right
and um I don't think we can say anything
about how Ron DeSantis is going to play
nationally
very popular Governor because Florida
has been doing well since he's been
governor and you know and it's worth
remembering that he got into office like
by the barest of majorities I mean he
was in a really tight race so his win is
gigantic like you know he's just Inc he
has a mandate you know in Florida now
but we've seen that before it's in
different circumstances but people like
Jeb Bush who is a very popular Florida
government didn't really do much on a on
a national stage uh he had been out of
office for a number of years so it's a
little bit different he was older
um you know DeSantis is Young vibrant
and coming off of this win but I think
if we're going to ask that question then
we also have to ask is Gavin Newsom the
future of the democratic party because
he has one extremely you know big
elections he survived a recall in
California and has you know National
Ambitions Jared Polis in Colorado walked
to Victory and represents a different
type of governance and I think either
DeSantis or Newsom so I don't know I
mean I I don't think we can say anything
about how uh what DeSantis plays on a
national stage it's also not fully clear
I mean is Trump still the main thing you
know the main guy in the Republican
Party supposedly a day after we record
this is going to announce that he's
running for president and we'll you know
we'll see
um I do think it's really important to
note that you know the Trump candidates
and the the guy in Michigan who unseated
Peter Meyer who had you know basically
scared off Justin Amash
um you know lost big because he is
exactly the type of candidate that Trump
and Trump Republicans tend to back which
is somebody with little or no experience
literal or no you know reality testing
skills and they're going to lose is the
Santa's good or bad for Libertarians I
think on net he is uh it's a mixed bag
and probably bad or rather I would like
to see us do better if you get a
DeSantis who is pretty good you know he
was good on covid pretty good on school
choice but then terrible on you know on
these kind of uh CRT laws and a variety
of other culture War activities he is
awful and we can't settle for that uh
would he be better than Gavin Newsom as
president absolutely I recently heard a
friend describe descentesis as a
representative of the new futonism which
is the culture the new confusionism
which is culture War grandstanding to
keep people sort of to get attention
combined with relatively competent you
know ex like executive Administration
and governance
oh no I think there's something to that
but with DeSantis the things and this is
the shift from you know state to Fat you
know to National stuff what's his what
is his policy on immigration what is his
policy on free trade what is his foreign
policy we know you know and those are
major major issues that will change the
way Independence certainly view him but
also Republicans also well and isn't
this I mean this to me is the concern
with DeSantis he has demonstrated clear
authoritarian type impulses on some of
the issues that he has chosen to kind of
foreground he also has demonstrated that
he is willing to make everything part of
the culture War that's his winning
formula and so you know I think the
answer to what is his immigration policy
isn't going to be well he has thought
deeply about the trade-offs for the
American economy and you know where the
Constitutional lines lie for the limits
of his power and then he's going to kind
of come up with the policy based on what
he thinks would be the best no it's
going to be
is shouting about this in a certain way
going to win me an election great I will
shout about it in that way and so in
that sense I think
even what you said in your earlier
answer Nick is I'm not sure it's true
that DeSantis will be better for you
know people who kind of hold libertarian
views than say and knew some presidency
um and that's just because I don't think
we know what his policies are Beyond
whatever the culture War filter strains
out as a winning strategy and I I just
think that's worth really clearly
caveating when we say like he's done
some things we don't hate um he has he's
done some things we don't hate but
that's no guarantee that he will do them
in the future
I I absolutely agree I do think you know
when you look at covid he was right and
he was following a logic there that was
important and also you know the if if
the model of governance is between high
taxes and promised High Services you
know which is California Gavin Newsom or
lower taxes lower regulation in general
and and lower levels of services you
know I think
um that's a meaningful choice and
DeSantis has an edge from a Libertarian
perspective and I say that as somebody
who's totally repulsed by virtually
everything about it his immigration
yeah we just have Jared Polis for
president so let's let's I think that's
a you know it's a real question and also
when polis goes to the National stage he
won't be as libertarian as we like to
see in certain aspects of his government
I'm more willing to be disappointed by
the police in the ways I think polis
will disappoint me than I am to be
disappointed by either Newsom or
DeSantis in the ways I think they will
disappoint me and if that isn't my
politics in a nutshell I don't know what
is yeah all of these people just and
another thing if if we may about like
when Governors leave their state and go
National I was talking with people the
other night about Chris Christie and
remember there was a Chris Christie
moment where he was he just seemed real
and great and wonderful and I was a
columnist for time at the at the moment
and I write like there's no [ __ ] way
Chris Christie is going to make it
outside of New Jersey he's perfect for
New Jersey and as I've bored everybody
with I know New Jersey well because I
grew up there and it was absolutely true
what worked to make him a kind of media
are in New Jersey in the New York media
area meant he was poisoned outside and
you know there's a Florida man to
mention to Ron DeSantis that might
really not play well once you creep
north of uh you know the Florida I think
the Santa Christy comparison is an
interesting one but also it's not just
Christy even though he's probably the
best example of that but like what
governor in recent history has had a
good presidential run when they've tried
to make that jump right there are so
many disappointments on that list Jeb
and Christy and Greg Abbott and I mean
it's like Mitt Romney the recent Mitt
Romney Bush George Bush is the last one
but since him it's been it's been
Senators that become president that have
sort of a national brand and a national
name recognition or you know people like
Donald Trump who have huge name
recognition uh Governors I think do kind
of get buttonholed into like or
pigeonhole they should say into uh like
being from a particular place and that
makes them somewhat unpalatable to
people who are not from that place it's
you know it's also kind of fascinating
when you think about this in the future
of the Republican party like Doug Ducey
who was term Limited out in Arizona you
know very conservative socially and
whatnot but looser and less culture
worry on these issues but like no I
don't know what his plans are nobody is
talking about him except that he's he
you know it was nice knowing him and
he's kind of dead and that's kind of
curious to think about that to be the
leader of the Republican party you
really have to be a trumpian figure you
have to be a loudmouth and somebody
who's very engaged in culture War issues
whatever else you're doing so I do want
to switch Focus to the Democrats here
um and in fact to a senator this weekend
Democratic Senator Elizabeth Warren of
she has a plan for that had an op-ed in
the New York Times titled Democrats just
held the Senate here's what we do next
what we do next turned out to be a lot
more of the same more spending more
taxation more spending did I mention
more spending uh basically it was an
argument that Democrats would take
Biden's big government approach that he
has had over the last couple of years
and run with it expand on it so Eric do
you agree with word I mean do you think
that that is what's going to happen uh
what should we expect if not
well that's tough to say but I will say
let me start with by saying something
positive about this I appreciate that
Elizabeth Warren is talking about policy
a couple of days after an election right
and I think you can sort of pair this
piece with the Mitt Romney op-ed that
was in the Wall Street Journal last week
where he said uh another thing that I
agree with which is like hey Republicans
maybe we should actually have an agenda
maybe we should talk about uh you know
liberalizing trade and opening up
immigration and maybe we should have an
actual platform that we can take to
voters
um and so I I think those two as the
sort of figures of their party that are
going to be interested in making a
policy argument they will get shouted
down and we will get into the
presidential campaign and everyone will
forget about that in like maybe two
months but there is maybe a brief window
of time where both parties can kind of
have a little opportunity here to move
the ball forward on their respective
agendas
um I think Elizabeth Warren is is vastly
overstating the extent to which
Democrats got any sort of mandate here
it's the it's the same thing that they
misunderstood two years ago which is
they had a 50 50 Senate and they
happened to have the vice president and
they took that to mean oh the voters
have given us the authority to do
whatever we want
um that's obviously not true it looks
like they're definitely gonna have at
least 50 plus uh Kamala Harris and they
may have 51 depending on the results in
Georgia but it's still going to be a
situation like we've been in for the
last couple of years where uh Joe
manchin and Kirsten Cinema and a couple
other members of the democratic caucus
in the Senate are going to have a
tremendous amount of power to influence
what can actually get done and then of
course you have the fact that the
Republicans control the house so I mean
I don't know I don't see Congress really
doing much of anything on these big
issues in the next few years except I
hope that maybe we can talk about stuff
like uh entitlement reform maybe like
things that both parties have to agree
on to get accomplished and things that
need to get done in the next decade
before everything thing goes to hell
Catherine this will not be a total loss
for Republicans if they manage to retake
the house which is uh likely not quite
certain but quite likely as of this
morning and that will give us as Eric
said that will give us divided
government with a republican check on
Biden and Senate Democrats so at minimum
that should end the kind of partisan
spending bills we saw over the last
couple of years Libertarians are often
fans of divided government you're a
Libertarian you love divided government
right
this is exciting for you big moment you
know I used to be a skeptic of this
Theory as I think I've said on this
podcast
um just you know even for my cold Little
Robot heart it always struck me a little
bit too cynical that our best case
scenario was just like a bunch of
stumble bunnying around because no one
can get anything done and
um it turned out that I was too
optimistic and that I should have
embraced this Theory from the beginning
I think divided government is good
though I think our recent experiment in
divided government has shown that the
benefit might actually be in checking
the internal kind of desire to go big on
the part of each party that only holds a
very very narrow majority that that
actually to me was the upside of this
last couple of years it wasn't oh the
Republicans are stopping the Democrats
from doing bad things and vice versa it
was when you only have 51 votes when you
only have the bear bear majority for
your party you have to get internal
agreement in your party and that that my
that's the moderating force um and I
think that that reflects a thing that
I've always believed which is that you
know in the spectrum of Any Given party
most of the people aren't insane I know
that it's you know these days we have a
lot of affective polarization and that
we want we have this notion that somehow
um we are going to you know if we can
only Vanquish the bad guys with a
different color on their but their
bumper stickers that then good will be
done when in fact I think most people
who vote for most parties and even in
fact most people who hold office under
the auspices of most parties are
relatively reasonable and trying to do
the right thing and that um creating
this very very narrow majority is a
moderating Force for good
um I wouldn't believe that if we were
moderating
you know libertarian impulses right like
I am I am ultimately you know I want to
see
um fairly revolutionary changes I want
to see big difference in the way that we
do government from the way we do
government right now failing that being
on the menu though uh I kind of like
this version of divided government in
which the parties are checked internally
by their own tiny margins so one last
thing I want to argue uh ask about here
nick uh is uh something that Eric
mentioned one of the last undecided
races is in Georgia where Senate
candidates Herschel Walker and Rafael
Warnock will go to a runoff since
neither of them got 50 of the vote there
was another candidate on the ballot this
time uh libertarian Chase Oliver who got
just over two percent of the vote and
now both sides are blaming him for
spoiling the race so our Libertarians
playing spoiler here is that what's
happening is it really Chase Oliver's
fault
it is absolutely you know that a sitting
you know Senator couldn't get 50 of the
vote you know only because of a
Libertarian and an inexperienced
incompetent Republican candidate
basically tied him again not with 50 of
the voted so obviously Libertarians are
spoilers here what I think is most
interesting about the race in Georgia is
that I think it encapsulates Georgia is
an interesting state where it's you know
it it's not really purple but there are
hard you know defined parts that are
read to find parts that are blue
um and neither you know this is where
the country is when you look at Exit
polling Independents are split down the
middle in terms of the party you know
that they uh they have more preference
for and things like that so I think
Georgia in a lot of ways is exactly
where the country is and what is good
about this and the way that chase Oliver
is talking about this is he wants to
have public conversations with each of
the candidates before he says hey you
know what like I'm not in the runoff but
like this person has either promised uh
to do something that's in a Libertarian
you know uh frame of mind or something
like that I like that a lot I I think
this also shows and this is something
that Matt and I talked about in the
Declaration of Independence the party
that adopts a couple of key libertarian
elements and goes with them and they can
even stack them on their existing stupid
piles of crap that they're going to do
because the Republicans are Democrats is
going to win the country has been split
I mean this is the thing that we need to
keep you know hammering home neither
party has a stable majority because they
don't have messages or policies or
attitudes or mindsets that people you
know a majority of Americans want if you
go with a uh you know a a Libertarian
message whether it's about you know gay
marriage and lifestyle Freedom whether
it's about marijuana and other drug
legalization whether it's immigration
you name it stuff that people care about
in super majorities you are going to be
in a you're going to win every race that
you want to be in so I'm looking forward
to how that plays out uh particularly
the conversation and like whether or not
Oliver actually endorses one candidate
or another for the right as the final
element in our elections discussion I'm
going to go around the panel and have
everyone named one just one only one one
good thing and one only one again only
one bad thing about the midterm here so
it can be a specific race a ballot
initiative a narrative a trend line some
sort of argument uh just one good thing
and one bad thing that came out of this
as you see it Catherine let's go to you
first uh my one good thing I already
mentioned which is Jared Paul is a
success I really
um honestly in my pessimistic heart of
hearts thought you know he at this point
I would say is the only politician
actually holding office that I even
moderately like at this point and he won
that's great he won big he won for the
right reasons as far as I can tell you
know polling aside
um so that's my good news my bad news
actually is
I have always been a big fan of election
betting markets
um and uh you know have in fact I think
made secondary bets on the efficacy of
betting markets over the years they did
not do well in the selection they did
not perform well and uh John Stossel
actually has a little kind of Maya culpa
column up on the site about this because
he is also a big fan and in fact I think
even runs or helped set up
electionbettingodds.com
um which tracks a bunch of those I still
think betting markets are good and a
useful tool but I was sad at how badly
they performed in this cycle
Eric
uh I'm gonna cheat and sort of copy off
Catherine here but it's it's a little
bit bigger than just Jared Paul's right
it's Colorado in general is the good
news here paulus won by almost 20 points
but then look the third congressional
district Lauren bobert who's one of
these like super trumpy members of
Congress very nearly lost it looks now
like she's gonna pull it out by less
than half a point but she nearly lost to
what's basically a blue dog Democrat
these people all went extinct over the
last couple of decades but here's a guy
Adam Frisch who was talking about like
cutting the deficit and cutting spending
and he's running as a Democrat and he
almost took down a uh hardcore Maga
Republican in western Colorado that's
great look at the ballot initiatives in
Colorado too this is a state that just
re-elected a Democratic governor by 20
points but the people voted uh on one of
the initiatives to cut the state income
tax rate hey that's great uh they also
voted to legalize uh some types of uh
some types of of mushrooms and other
psychedelic drugs
um and there was a third ballot
initiative that I was excited about too
and I think I've lost that one oh they
allow wine sales and Grocery and
convenience stores like this is all the
stuff that Libertarians want is all
happening in Colorado at once uh not
just all the stuff that we want but
maybe not all this stuff that's many
good things right just the wine and
Grocery and convenience stores I'm good
fine all of these things are exciting uh
that they're all happening together
Founders and if Democrats want to win
races in places that aren't the two
coasts they should look at what people
are voting for in Colorado because
there's probably a sign there uh the
negative is uh the fact that and we
touched on this a little bit earlier too
the fact that like so many of these
basically unelectable hard Maga
Republican candidates that were that
were boosted by democrats in the primary
so many of them lost because I think
going forward I mean I'm happy that they
lost but going forward I think that
teaches both parties a really bad lesson
and I think we will see that same sort
of shenanigans happen more and more
which is uh unfortunate and probably bad
for the country and for like democracy
in general I really only got two good
things and one I mentioned before which
is that the secretary now I'm losing the
negative the Secretary of States you
know who were denying the veracity of
the election results the 2020 election
was like the most vetted election in
American history there was not
widespread significant systematic you
know voter fraud the election results
were pretty goddamn solid and the people
who were running against that all lost
with one exception I think that's good
news the other good news is that
abortion valid initiatives did really
well because it turns out you know what
Dan Quayle had said Back in 88 when he
was running his George H.W Bush's
presidential uh Contender and Bush
himself when he became Reagan's vice
president flip-flopped after you know
talking about being pro-choice uh to
become staunchly anti-abortion danquel
admitted that like he is against
abortion but if his daughters got
pregnant he would want that as an option
that's what we're seeing everywhere and
I still think that abortion should be
settled at the national level I think it
is a fundamental right but it's good to
see people recognizing that you don't
want the government making medical
decisions and that ultimately what it is
so I just have two good things all right
well I have a good news and a bad news
and in some ways they're the same the
good news is that Republicans lost and
in particular trumpy Mega Maniac types
lost
um and while I don't know that everyone
in the Republican party is going to
learn the right lessons from that I
think or at least I hope some will and
it will probably have a salutatory
effect on the Republican party but the
corollary the flip side of that is the
bad news is that Democrats won and they
won on some really tangential
tendentious irritating arguments and as
Eric said they also won in part by
cynically boosting really awful uh
trumpy Maga inexperienced candidates and
that strategy worked and I think they
are going to learn some very bad very
unfortunate lesson from that okay before
we go on let's stop for just a bit and
say that this show is sponsored by
better help
you ever wish life came with a user
manual like a YouTube help video you
know when you don't know how to fix your
dishwasher but for you and your brain
and your feelings unfortunately life
doesn't come with a user manual so when
it's not working for you it's normal to
feel stuck navigating life's challenges
can make you feel uncertain whether it's
a career change a new relationship
hosting a podcast on Monday morning when
you don't really know what you're
supposed to be saying therapists are
trained to help you figure out the cause
of challenging emotions and learn
productive coping skills which makes
therapy the closest thing to a guided
tour of the complex engine called you
as the world's largest therapy service
betterhelp has matched three million
people with professionally licensed and
vetted therapists available 100 online
plus it's affordable just fill out a
brief questionnaire to match with a
therapist if things aren't clicking you
can easily switch to a new therapist
anytime it could not be simpler no
waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist learn
more and save 10 percent off your first
month at betterhelp.com Roundtable
that's betterhelp.com Roundtable
okay let's move on to this week's
listener question uh which comes from
listener QB who writes Brazil is a
country with over 200 million people and
they counted all of their presidential
election votes on Election night U.S
Democrats however need weeks to count
all their votes what other explanation
is this uh then what other explanation
for this is there than cheating so this
is I think representative of uh of a
line of thinking that I've heard
elsewhere complaints have surfaced over
the last week with Tucker Carlson
comparing U.S elections unfavorably to
Venezuela of all places and even Nancy
Pelosi seemed annoyed at how long it's
taking to count the votes she told ABC
News this weekend I wish it would be
faster but it isn't so Eric why is it
taking so long to count the votes
uh well it takes it's always taken a
while to count the votes right I think
there's sort of there's two responses to
this and the first one is that this sort
of assumes that things used to be better
in the past or something like that I I
don't remember a time when we got like
all the results on Election Day anyway
there have always been close races
um another part of it though has to do
and specifically the like comparison to
pres to Brazil here is interesting
because Brazil uses uh electronic voting
for all of their vote counting which
obviously speeds things up but can be
subject to Shenanigans can be subject to
uh to concerns about whether it's you
know legit or not and so we use and a
lot of you know every part of the
country every state runs its own uh
elections under its own uh its own
system but there are a lot of uh paper
ballots there are a lot of uh you know
stuff that is counted by hand
um and then we're also kind of learning
how to go through the mail-in vote uh
process which we which we did in 2020
and I think much more effectively this
time around but uh States you know last
time certainly a lot of states were not
counting their mail and vote until uh
after election day some states have
fixed that um but it's to me it's a
little bit disingenuous because you hear
this argument from the right frequently
of like oh why is it taking so long for
us to count votes and why is it taking
so long for uh the results to come in
that must be signs of fraud when it's
like the reason why a lot of states have
these rules about having paper ballots
and having a paper trail and not using
electronic voting is also because of
concerns that the right has pushed in
the past about voter fraud and they want
that the paper record there so so you
kind of can't have it both ways like if
you want the results to go quickly you
can't do the hand counting Nick the
slowness of the count isn't just
annoying it's pretty obviously just
based on the listener's question helping
to sow distrust about politics about our
elections is that something you worry
about and are there voting process
reforms you think we should consider to
help make the vote counts go faster not
particularly uh you know I think that
the most important thing like when you
say there is an issue and the only thing
that can explain it is what I personally
believe you know I don't think you're
going to reach that person
um and I don't know that it's worth
conversing with them whether they're
they're woke activists or voter fraud uh
enthusiasts or whatever the voting
system works really well as Eric was
talking about we have moved because of
covet and other reasons which makes
sense to all sorts of voting early
voting as well as kind of late voting
and tallying and then certifying
elections there's no fraud at any
significant rate even in Republican
states where they looked for it in order
to re-elect Donald Trump nobody found
anything there's really nothing to worry
about here the most important thing to
recognize and this is the message of the
21st century with the 2000 presidential
election elections are really close now
because each party sucks and everybody
knows it so like more and more races are
coming down to the wire you know the
reason why Arizona is going to have to
wait for a while is because Carrie Lake
should have been able to win easily but
she's nuts and out to lunch and even die
hard Republicans in Arizona couldn't
pull the lever for her and they elect a
kind of mediocre Democrat who is not as
bad as a democrat in California
elections are close it takes a while to
figure out who's won it's not
complicated
Catherine to Eric's points you and I
were both in college in the year of Our
Lord 2000. and and you remember probably
turning on the news everywhere like
passing by the news in your like dorm
hall or wherever it was right like just
it was kind of on in the air and
literally every other sentence was just
too close to call too close to call and
like it became like at least where I was
in at school like it became this rutting
gag because it was like lasted months
and months they couldn't say anything
all they could say was too close to call
so I guess it was cheating back then
right yeah I mean I uh spent the
election night of 2000 playing a game of
of risk because we thought like Oh by
the time this game of Risk is over we'll
know who won by the time you're in yeah
yeah Ukraine um but the uh no I think
this question asked her I disagree with
Nick I think that people uh it is worth
talking about this because I think that
um
this particular subspecies of concern
about election malfeasance is subject to
disproof um and what Eric said is right
there's nothing new about the delay
which is highly significant but I also
think this is a really classic hanlands
razor moment never a tribute to malice
that which could be adequately explained
by stupidity this isn't this is evidence
that people are bad at things not that
people are part of an evil conspiracy
but they're not bad at things some
states have quit some some states count
the ballots ahead of time and then other
states that are subject to these
conspiracy theories are not following
best practices they have chosen
incompetence
for a variety of reasons and um of
course there are Bad actors of course
there's someone in each of these days
there's someone somewhere in the system
who thinks that maybe they can in fact
break the rules and turn this to their
advantage but those people are not by
and large empowered by the system and
the delays are a product of screwing
around not
malfeasance okay I want to move on from
the elections to something that's much
more important to most normal Americans
Elon musk's Twitter and his experiment
with a paid verification scheme Twitter
blue we're going to call this segment
even Elon gets the blues Elon Musk Elon
Musk implemented a new form of Twitter
blue in which users could pay for blue
check verification even if they weren't
in some cases the person or brand they
claim to be in their account and so the
result was a lot of pure comedy uh
parody account OPP posing as the
Chiquita banana brand tweeted that they
had just overthrown the Brazilian
governments I guess that's how we got
the fast vote count there was a fake
Tesla account that tweeted breaking a
second Tesla has hit the World Trade
Center maybe maybe a little too soon for
that one so not everyone thought this
stuff was funny after a Washington Post
uh report uh said that they were able to
create a fake verified account for
Democratic senator Ed Markey Markey
wrote a sharply worded letter to Elon
Musk demanding responses to a whole
bunch of questions with like a a
deadline at the end of November and so
and musk's response was just to like
Twitter troll him and be like no I'm not
gonna do that why are you wearing a mask
in your avatar like why would you do
that like
so you know this didn't work out like at
the same time the parody stuff uh seemed
to be posing actual problems in late
last week the company did press pause on
the Twitter blue rollout over the
weekend Ben Smith's new inside media
newsletter at semaphore declared that
even the people who thought Elon knew
what he was doing are starting to have
doubts Twitter may be the most important
company in the history of news and it's
off the rails Nick what do you think of
that description the most important
company in the history of news and does
any of this worry of you right like does
all this drama shake your face if you
had any I guess to begin with in musk's
management abilities uh does it make you
in any way concerned about the future of
freedom of speech online like does this
like is this does this sort of thing
seem like it actually matters to you or
is this just funny because we got a
bunch of funny tweets uh you know two
quick things to say about it and the
first is musk's takeover and you know
cutting of the workforce and all of that
everything he is doing doing is
completely within the range of what any
new owner does of a business that has
been in trouble uh you know period and
everybody forgets that for the past
decade people have been saying Twitter
is a [ __ ] show it's a hellscape it needs
to be changed blah blah blah and you get
somebody who actually starts doing this
um there there's a um a reason a Super
Fan named Ron Hayden who was at next the
uh company that Steve Jobs started after
he got ousted from Apple and then went
from next back to Apple and Ron went
with Steve Jobs and he talked about in a
great Twitter thread just about you know
how what's going on at uh at Twitter is
exactly what what uh jobs did when he
came back to Apple which really needed
an overhaul so the the reporting on this
is very pointed and it's all just
anti-musk stuff having said that I think
musk will likely fail you know at
Twitter because it's hard to change
companies and it's hard to grow them
when they start to Flap line and things
like that so we'll see that worries me I
think Twitter is great I love Twitter I
think Twitter is still funny the larger
question of will it invite government uh
oversight you know that's a real
question because Ed Markey always wants
to take over things uh that this is his
you know his stock in trade he's been
pushing you know for the FCC to have
control over everything including this
podcast for his entire career he's awful
in that way I do think that the way that
Elon Musk is talking about stuff it's
going to make it more likely that the
government just to troll him is going to
start you know flexing more and more on
social media and that worries me for the
same reason it worried me long before
musk was talking about buying Twitter
yeah that's my concern as well and this
I guess I just want to put this question
to Catherine real quick here is uh this
is such a circus
and it's and the circus aspect of it
makes Twitter and Elon Musk a high
profile Target and so my worry here is
that it is going to invite regulatory
oversight on scrutiny simply because
musk seems to like the fact that it is a
circus and he seems to enjoy being the
ringleader and and so I I am enjoying
this myself as a consumer of funny
tweets
but I think certain Senators don't see
it that way and that this may end up
drawing attention to uh not just to
Twitter but to online speech and online
speech regulation you know we've got um
big Supreme Court cases on Section 230
coming up and that stuff is you know
legislatively still up in the air
Catherine do you worry that maybe musk
is sort of making too too much noise
here
um and that that in and of itself the
noise aspect of this is going to is
going to generate attention from
Congress and and and Regulators in ways
that's not going to be productive you
know I absolutely would have said that
was a worry
um I would have sort of phrased it
exactly as you phrased it as I was
listening to you asked that question
though I got mad because that's not how
it should be it's absolutely infuriating
that we live under a system where like
being noisy attract tracks the attention
of regulators it's like some kind of
horror movie like that one with the
Sandra Bullock and the
mask or whatever like I don't know
there's like you know there's this this
idea that like we have to like keep our
you know keep our heads down or the or
the Regulators will come for us and that
it's entirely a product of of kind of an
artificial set of uh criteria that
include media attention that would bring
regulation upon you that's messed up man
that's that's not right
um this has always been true right I
mean if it was Walmart before it was
Amazon it was you know there's always
been some brands that sort of raised the
ire
of regulators and that also make for
good content and so people pay attention
and they get a disproportionate amount
of you know legal and Regulatory
attention as a result I will say more
broadly like I'm out here trying to
defend Elon you know I like the Rockets
as you know I I it's like when it comes
to Elon like I'm not angry I'm
disappointed you know I wanna like
have a sit down with him
um because he has so much potential and
he is squandering it
um you know I
I think that
he is choosing to cast himself as a kind
of super villain I agree with you that
actually the biggest risk is is the
regulatory risk and I as I say I think
that's sort of upsetting and wrong but I
also think there's a genuine cost to
like Humanity which is that he's some of
his other Ventures have very very very
clear positive consequences for our
future like electric cars and Rockets to
get off this god-forsaken planet are
both clearly valuable the tunnel thing
uh we'll see but it's um
you know it does really strike me as a
distraction
um like I have seen the best minds of my
generation like Twitter has ruined them
historical tweeting first among them
yeah I think this is the the case
against Elon musk's Twitter even if it
doesn't end up having any impact
legislatively or you should have you
know with with Regulators is just is
this really the thing that is most
valuable that he could be doing with his
time
like I waste my time like if you were
like hey Catherine are you using your
time to better no I watch a bunch of
Netflix last week like I get it that's
right but still I I want I want I want
him to do more and better his time is
his private property that's correct just
like Twitter and now uh and so he fired
a bunch of people um thousands of of
Staff about half the staff uh including
a bunch of people uh on the
misinformation and disinformation team
apparently and I guess that's one of the
concerns that uh that folks have is that
oh well because he's it's now
understaffed they're not going to be
able to effectively police or manage
misinformation on Twitter Eric how
worried are you about Elon musk's
Staffing choices at Twitter right now do
you think this is like something that's
gonna impact the future of America and
political discourse no no I don't know
like it's like Twitter's always been a
mess and then like the people who really
care deeply about Twitter and there's
like you know one tenth of one half of
one percent of Americans are in this
category right like every time the font
changes on your Twitter page or whatever
right people freak out about it some
people are just way too invested in like
what Twitter is uh Twitter is uh it's
always been this kind of weird circus I
guess is probably the nicest way to put
it
um and so no no like it'll it'll
continue to evolve and change and it'll
continue to be the source of like memes
and jokes and and breaking news content
which is it's actual like only really
useful uh purpose and uh the other stuff
I don't know if senators and
representatives want to come like
banging down Elon musk's store to
investigate him over Twitter they're the
ones who are wrong about that uh that
has nothing to do with musk's decisions
or the merits of them think about
Twitter though like if Twitter didn't
exist there's a good argument that
Donald Trump wouldn't have become
president I don't I don't I don't think
I buy that either like I just I don't
think it's anywhere near as influential
as people think it is I think of people
who are in the Twitter bubble overstated
no but it's not the Twitter bubble
leaked into you know the Legacy Media he
was also huge on Facebook so social
media the fact that CNN covered is
covered why did they do that thing to
end for six months not because of
Twitter because they thought they were
getting good rates
was able to directly address people and
other politicians are Twitter in its
beginning you know when it helped
facilitate and enable the Arab Spring
and other kinds of early movements and
so it is important to have an unmediated
me you know social media platform or
whatever you want to call it where
people good and bad can talk directly
and then that gets picked up by existing
channels so yeah no disagreement I would
lament the end of Twitter especially if
the future looks like something like
Mastodon and this is something where a
bunch of journalists are saying
everybody's leaving Twitter and going to
to Mastodon simply not true and when you
look at the way that Mastodon or
decentralized uh social media platforms
operate they're not going to be as
influential because they don't have the
same kind of reach um weirdly Twitter
you know in Facebook to a certain degree
both of which are kind of fading so that
means they'll definitely be regulated
because the government loves to regulate
companies in their dying days but they
replace mass media not by having
centralized networks or nodes that
destroy tribute stuff that you can't get
away from or you have to watch when
they're doing it but by creating mass
platforms where individuals can really
route around all sorts of blockage and
Gatekeepers and that's a real loss if
that happens whether it's because of
Elon Musk or because of regulators
but I think if anything if we get rid of
the the disinformation teams or whatever
at Twitter that probably benefits the
platform as a like dissemination point
for you know movements that would
otherwise be shut down or viewpoints
that would otherwise be shut down so I'm
fine with that I don't think that like
if Twitter dies it won't be because musk
fired the disinformation team
I do not blame Twitter for Donald Trump
becoming president I blame Macaulay
Culkin because if he hadn't been so damn
cute in Home Alone 1 there wouldn't have
been a home alone too and thus there
wouldn't have been a Donald Trump cameo
in Home Alone 2 making him a famous
movie star perpetuating the myth of
Donald Trump that led to the Apprentice
you go back to 2016 and you see that The
Apprentice of apprentice viewers
actually formed like a the molten Corps
of Donald Trump's support for presidents
it was Macaulay Culkin and his cute kid
actor face that gave us Donald Trump and
that's my story the only feature I want
to see by the way for for Twitter is
that when someone is trending like a
famous person especially an old person
anybody over 50 even 40. I want the
trending tab to make clear that they're
not dead or or that they are I guess if
they are okay uh let's go to our end of
show what you're watching what you're
consuming
um Catherine let's start with you yes I
I read uh a book called The Long ships
it's by Franz
bendigson he's Swedish the book was
written in 1955 and
um it was sent to me as part of the um
again extremely welcome Deluge of
content after my scooter accident
um by Andy Rotherham you can see him in
a video that we made a couple years ago
about busing for Charter Schools he's an
ed policy dude but uh upon hearing that
I would not be making it to our lunch he
said I'm gonna send you a book and this
book has an introduction by Michael
siobone where he basically says I'm
weirdly obsessed with this book and
you're going to read it and you will be
too it is a faux Viking Saga so it's
written in 1955 but it's set in the 10th
century and has big uh kind of fake
historical text energy uh which I really
enjoy and uh it's great it's like uh
it's just like a wonderful weird
adventure story it's what I kind of
wanted Moby Dick to be and yes I know
those are fighting words to a variety of
you know Melville stands out there
um extra bonus points are the fact that
when this book was published uh its
author refused to have it translated
into German
um or earlier version of this book was
published its author refused to have it
translated into German why because [ __ ]
the Nazis that's why
um so just you know everything good in
this book a nice long
um
absorbing work of historical fiction for
those who think they might like that
kind of thing the long ships by Franz G
bintixon I like the idea of a faux
Viking Saga it's like it's like the
pleather of Viking sagas yes that's
right it's uh
it's um just as shiny on the outside but
uh Less murdery on the inside a little
sauce why can't we actually do
historical historical history I mean do
we need another fake mythology to
remember now
um
yeah
I don't want to learn learn about Thor
and Marvel Comics or Game of Thrones you
better learn [ __ ] the Shire and
Tolkien you better learn to love Vikings
because in our current ERA of paranoia
about cultural appropriation Vikings are
what white people have we are going to
get a lot more Viking media that is one
of my predictions uh because it is not
hashtag problematic for people to white
people to dress up as Vikings make
movies about Vikings
cornrows and the hair extension so it's
getting problematic but I don't consider
myself white and certainly not Viking
white you know on the Irish side
my people were you know attacked by the
Vikings and on the Italian inside they
were southern Italy they were conquered
by everybody so a lot of praise for
Irish women in this book yeah obviously
they know not what they're talking of
but
the Northman was great and God of War
Ragnarok is getting great reviews
haven't played it yet Eric what have you
been consuming yeah on the other hand uh
I just watched the fourth Thor movie
last night and oh boy like that's not
great I hope our new our vicinity
doesn't go that direction
um I've been consuming better Viking
media Elon Musk make that happen for us
yeah that was a that was a stinker uh
I've been consuming being funny in a
foreign language this is the new
relatively new it came out last month uh
album from the 1975. I think it's their
fifth full-length album and I've always
kind of been a fan of theirs but this
one like really just struck me and like
grabbed on you know like it scratched
into my soul which is like a whole
steady line about when you really love
songs uh it's uh it's only like 45
minutes long so honestly everybody
should just like put that on as soon as
this podcast is over and listen to it
but I will recommend a couple tracks if
you don't want to listen to the whole
thing uh oh Caroline is like a real
Banger this is the one that if songs
still make it on the radio from bands
like the 1975 I don't know if they do
but this would be be the one wintering
sounds like an old Paul Simon song if
you're into that sort of thing but like
filtered through Jack Antonoff uh he
helped produce this whole album I'm a
huge fan of his uh you probably know him
a bit from his work with like Taylor
Swift and Lana Del Rey and Lord as well
as his former band Fun and bleachers
he's got his hands in like every single
project that's happening in like alt uh
music right now uh the opening song and
the closing song are both fantastic the
opener is called The 1975 somewhat
confusingly just like the name of the
band it's got this awesome little piano
riff in it that is I think a deliberate
nod to the LCD Soundsystem song all my
friends which is there's no room for
debate about this the best LCD
Soundsystem song number one no doubt uh
and it's and it's interesting because I
think this is the little libertarian
hook here is that uh the whole album and
especially the first and last track are
kind of about like online culture and
like bad tweets and your experience in
your 20s when you're still sort of
finding your place
um in the in the world and in in online
especially um there's a line in the
first song about I'm sorry about my 20s
I was learning the ropes I had a
tendency of thinking about it after I
spoke or experiencing life through the
postmodern lens oh call it like it is
and then that whole theme kind of comes
back on the last track too when we are
together which is also just like
delicious and beautiful
um it sits somewhere in like the Bon
Iver to Phoebe Bridger spectrum and uh
the fiddle bit on it in particular is
really really good and uh sort of
evocative of moon song from Phoebe
bridger's last album actually and uh and
again it sort of deals with this
question of like cancel culture and
online culture Maddie Healy the lead
singer of The 1975 sort of got canceled
a little bit back during the black lives
matter protests for some things that he
tweeted he then subsequently deactivated
his Twitter account which makes him
smarter than most of the rest of us on
this podcast and uh the resolution of
all this tension throughout the album is
that basically none of that [ __ ]
online really matters as long as you
have like people that love you and
Walmart toy departments yes really like
capitalism and love are kind of the
resolution at the end of the album uh it
is beautiful everyone should listen to
it uh being funny in a foreign language
by the 1975. so Point number one the
best LCD sound system I knew you were
gonna argue about this the best LCD
sound system song is Losing My Edge and
in particular the live performance from
their goodbye show which turned out not
to actually be their last show at the
Madison Square Garden but Point number
two speaking of Madison Square Garden
have you heard been reading the coverage
of the 1975's live shows to promote this
album because apparently uh the singer
is doing things like eating huge chunks
of raw meat on stage and miming
touching himself
in front of like Giant videos of Ben
Shapiro he's a weird dude he's a weird
dude makes good art like but dude
actually happening on stage anyway it's
apparently
um pretty nuts uh okay so I'll I'll go
next year uh I saw black panther wakanda
forever it is the sequel to Black
Panther which is one of the very best
Marvel movies wakanda forever is not one
of the very best Marvel movies it's
ambitious and at times it is shot
through with some real emotion because
it pays tribute to Chadwick Boseman the
star of black panther who played the
character black panther
um and who died tragically in his early
40s of cancer before this movie could be
made
um the moments where the movie pays
tribute to Chadwick Boseman I think
largely work but this is just an
overstuffed bloated kind of uh sort of
Marvel movie in in not quite the worst
possible way but in a lot of ways that
just don't work there's so much set up
for other stuff there's a whole long
sort of a side plot that's setting up
the Iron Heart television show uh it's
sort of which is gonna you know end up
being that the Iron Heart television
show Earnhardt is about a young woman
who invents an Iron Man suit well of
course she is gonna gonna that and then
ironheart will end up playing a role in
armor Wars which was gonna be a series
but now it's gonna be a movie and then
there's this whole Julia Louise Dreyfus
subplot where it's like she's married to
the guy who was in The Hobbit movies uh
or was married to him she's his ex-wife
and it's just like this is a two and a
half hour movie and 45 minutes of it are
basically teasers for other Marvel stuff
and those teasers aren't all that
interesting and also the movie kind of
just looks like garbage it's genuinely
shocking how bad and like unartful it's
just sort of badly crafted this 200
million dollar film is so there's some
interesting ideas there and I think the
the trio of of lead performances they
basically took the The Supporting Cast
from the first black panther and put
them at Center Stage I think those
performances are all quite good it's not
a total disaster this movie is certainly
better than something like the all the
eternals um which similar sort of
bloated uh movie The you know Marvel
movie that came out it's still going on
the eternals never really ended
but like think about the titles to both
of these the eternals wakanda forever
it's just like these are the comments on
the the running time uh and I just I it
was a big disappointment it really
didn't work for me and I say that as
somebody who's a very big fan of the
first film uh so Nick let's end with you
and tell us not only what you've been
watching but what we should watch out
for that you have in store for us okay
uh so you know there's the reason to
interview podcast which comes out every
Wednesday and I'll start with that uh
the next one is with Andrew koppelman
who wrote a book called Burning Down The
House uh which is a critique of
libertarianism uh from the mid-century
mid-20th Century to now he essentially
says that we've left Hayek behind and
embrace rothbart and that's a problem I
agree with him in that large sweep of
things but we disagree on virtually
everything else including the anecdote
that gives the title to his house the
other thing is on December 1st in New
York City we're doing a reason Speak
Easy with Caitlin Bailey who is the head
of a group called Old Pros it's a sex
worker Rights group uh she's fantastic
she also does a one-woman show called
horse eye view which is a comic but
serious look at uh 10 000 years of
prostitution uh that's great so that's
coming up go to reason.com events to see
that as well as Soho Forum events and
anything else that's happening what I
watched and I'll be brief because this
is beautiful and perfect I uh have uh
been consuming hanging with Dr Z which
is the comedian Dana gold who did Dana
Gould who has worked with everybody uh
was also on Seinfeld did a great early
web series called Murray Wilson rock and
roll genius with Peter bagg try and find
that online it's very funny but he plays
Dr zayas from Planet of the Apes as a
late as a 70 style uh late night talk
show host
um if you liked Space Ghost Coast to
Coast this is a version of that on kind
of psychedelics it is funny it's
interesting it is timeless and I think a
lot of people would describe Space Ghost
Coast to Coast as a non-psychedelics
already
this is another level this is another
level it's extremely funny even more
self-referential and I think unlike uh
you know learning false histories what a
show like uh hanging with Dr Z does is
it it is the last place you can go to
remember a rapidly uh deteriorating and
disappearing ephemeral culture of of
post-war television late night
television I'll just say hanging with Dr
Z give it 15 minutes it's free on
YouTube it's extremely funny and uh it
will make you want to know more about
the past than you ever thought you
wanted to
all right I will um I will definitely do
everyone a favor here and not end this
show by doing my zorak Impressions do
you have a keyboard
the super villain who was captured by
Space Ghost and forced to play his band
leader and also the actual funniest
thing I ever saw when I was 14. like for
like for a full year of my life I was
just kind of laughing cackling
hysterically because because of the
existence of zorak uh huge cultural
Touchstone for me all right that's all
the time we have for this week remember
if you like this podcast or others that
reason produces you can give us money
support reason to support the recent
Roundtable at reason.com donate that's
reason.com donate the reason Roundtable
will return in Thunderball
[Music]